In Sankt Johann im Pongau sind die
Krampusse los.
Der Nikolaus mit seinen Engeln führt die
wüsten Gestalten durch den Ort.
Und mittendrin, eindeutig zu erkennen: ich!
Sankt Johann am Morgen: Ich bin unterwegs
in den Ort.
Hier, knapp 60 Kilometer südlich von
Salzburg in Österreich, wird die Tradition des
Krampusʼ gepflegt – so wie in der ganzen
Region.
Ich treffe den Gründer einer
Krampus-Gruppe: Emmerich Köck.
Mitte der achtziger Jahre hat er eine
sogenannte „Pass“ gegründet.
Die besteht aus einem Nikolaus, Engeln,
einem Korbträger
und mehr als einem Dutzend Krampussen.
Aber Krampus – oder auch „Percht“ genannt
– ist er schon seit Kindertagen.
Ab dem zwölften Lebensjahr, da läufst du halt
so mit in den Orten in den verschiedenen,
und dann sagst du:
Ja, jetzt stellen wir mal was auf die Beine.
Schauen wir mal, ob wir ein paar Freunde
haben,
und so hat das angefangen mit neun Stück.
Und jetzt sind wir inzwischen 18 Perchten,
Nikolaus, zwei Engel, Korbträger.
So, Axel, und jetzt werde ich dir zeigen, was
los ist.
Jetzt gehen wir uns umziehen, und dann
gehtʼs los.
Gut!
Da haben wir jetzt einmal einen Anzug für
dich.
Da soll ich jetzt rein?
Du musst dir aber jetzt die Hose ausziehen.
Okay.
Emmerich?
Ja?
Ganz ehrlich: Das mit dem Ausziehen, das
hat mir hier vorher keiner gesagt.
Der Grund ist ganz einfach:
Auch bei Minustemperaturen wird es in dem
Schaffell-Anzug so warm,
dass jede Hose drunter völlig überflüssig ist.
So ein Anzug hält ungefähr fünf Jahre, dann
ist das Leder porös und reißt.
Dann, als Nächstes, kommt der
Schellengürtel,
mit dem die Krampusse Lärm schlagen. Und
zum Schluss:
die Maske! Alles zusammen wiegt gut 30 Kilo.
Es ist höllisch heiß
in dem Anzug, und die Maske ist tierisch eng.
Ich kann kaum sprechen,
ich sehe so gut wie nichts,
irgendwie nur durch den Augenschlitz, ein
bisschen durch den Mund.
Und ich weiß noch nicht, wie ich diesen Tag
überstehen soll.
Alles egal, denn jetzt wird es ernst.
Vorneweg geht der Nikolaus mit seinen
Engeln und dem Korbträger.
Dahinter wird es dann laut. Wir besuchen
einen Bauernhof am Rand von St. Johann.
Seid gegrüßt bei diesem Haus, jetzt spricht zu
euch der Nikolaus.
Da hier nur artige Kinder wohnen, bekommen
alle ein Geschenk vom Nikolaus.
Wir Krampusse halten uns eher im
Hintergrund.
Die schiere Masse der Masken wirkt von ganz
allein.
Danach beginnt der gemütliche Teil des
Besuchs.
Wir, also die „Köck-Pass“ ist von der Familie
eingeladen worden.
Für die Kinder ist das jedes Jahr schon
Wochen vorher so a Erlebnis,
dass die Kramperl zu uns und natürlich auch
der Nikolaus und die Engel
zu uns auffikommen, also sie haben da a
Mordsgaudi.
Weil es einfach ein Highlight in der
Adventszeit ist.
Da freut man sich dann noch mehr auf
Weihnachten.
Und Krampus und Nikolaus sind einfach …
gehören zu uns dazu.
Dann geht es weiter zum nächsten Auftritt.
Artgerecht werden Krampusse im
Viehanhänger transportiert.
Insgesamt haben wir heute vier
Hausbesuche.
An manchen Tagen können es auch doppelt
so viele sein.
In der guten Stube unserer vorletzten Station
ist es kuschelig warm.
Mir läuft im Fell der Schweiß in Strömen.
Durch die enge Maske kann ich kaum atmen.
Ich bin kurz davor, aufzugeben.
Nach einer schier endlosen Bescherung und
einem zweiten Weihnachtslied
ist es endlich vorbei!
Axel, super gemacht.
Vielen Dank!
Unser bester Deutschland-Krampus, was
[den] wir je gehabt haben.
Aber ganz geschafft habe ich es noch nicht.
Die Menschen in Sankt Johann
erwarten uns zum Krampus-Lauf.
Hier präsentieren sich mehr als ein Dutzend
Gruppen aus dem Ort. Und wir vorneweg.
Ich habʼs geschafft! Und ich bin völlig fertig!
Nach sieben Stunden in diesem
Ganzkörper-Schaffell hat das Sprichwort
„Schmoren im eigenen Saft“
noch mal ʼne ganz neue Bedeutung
bekommen.
Was mir auf jeden Fall am meisten gefallen
hat, ist,
dass die „Köck-Pass“ mich sofort
aufgenommen hat, als sei ich einer von ihnen.
Und ich bin auf jeden Fall um eine Erfahrung
reicher.